this is Sharda and this is Lina two  young servals  these slender medium-sized cats are  native to sub-saharan Africa and have a  gorgeous golden coat with black spots  servals have the longest legs of any cat  relative to body sizes  their ears are also impressively large  and converted 180 degrees giving them a  keen sense of hearing which helps them  locate prey efficiently their long lean  and can jump up to nine feet in the air  to catch unsuspecting birds flying by  beyond birds they mostly feed on rodents  insects and reptiles  servoz prefer wetlands and areas with  tall grasses near water  unfortunately degradation of these  wetlands is leaving them with less and  less space while hunting for their  prized Curt remains a big concern this  is the serval  [Music]